is the fusion GPS scandal about to blow
up plus Democrats shut down the
government but the media are about to
blame Republicans and we will check the
mailbag so many things to do today i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
oh I didn't to mention the fact that
President Trump apparently according to
certain reports asked a pornstar could
spank her with a with a or she could
spank him with a with a magazine cover
with his face on it so we'll have to
talk about that as well that is the most
Freudian thing I mean that is the more
that's so Freudian that similar Oedipus
was like I'm out man
I can't Electro's I know we're done but
we'll get to all of that in just a
second why no one cares but first we
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Skillshare so Skillshare is the
place to make sure that your skills are
up to par the fact is that you can't
hope that your skill set is just going
to cut it for the rest of your career I
mean the truth is your skill set
probably won't cut it for the next three
months you need to be constantly
updating what it is that you are good at
and what you can do that's what
Skillshare does for you right at the
beginning of the year is a perfect time
for you to make the commitment that you
are going to make your resume broader
and deeper and increase your skill set
that's what Skillshare does so
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 18,000 classes in
design business technology and more
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set or start a side
business or explore something new that's
what Skillshare does and they can help
you do that this year and beyond just in
time for the new year Skillshare is
offering my listeners a limited time
offer three months of skill shop for
just 99 cents I know their classes are
great we've taken some of it in social
media marketing here at the Ben Shapiro
show and I've taken one in watercolours
yes seriously to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99 can you
get a limited time offer of three months
of skill shop for just 99 cents again go
to skill shared comm slash Shapiro 99 to
get three months of skill share for just
99 cents act now for that special New
Year's offer start learning today skill
shared Calm Shapiro 99 make sure it's
Shapiro 99 so they know that we sent you
already so the big news over the evening
over the course of the evening was that
Republicans had called for the release
of a particular memo so what exactly is
this memo so according to Sarah Carter
who is a national security reporter she
says quote a review of a classified
document outlining what is described as
extensive foreign intelligence
surveillance act abuse was made
available to House members Thursday and
the revelations could lead to the
removal of senior officials in the FBI
and Department of Justice several
sources with knowledge of the document
stayed so what happened is in the House
Intelligence Committee there was a vote
to allow other members of the House to
take a look at this floor page
Democrats are claiming the memo is
selective evidence with regard
specifically to the Russian dossier and
Russian collusion Republicans are saying
this memo blows the lid off the entire
Russian collusion scandal sources say
the report is explosive
they were stating it would not they
would not be surprised and it leads to
the end of Robert Mueller Special
Counsel investigation into President
Trump and his associates the House
Intelligence Committee passed the motion
along party lines Thursday to make the
classified report alleging extensive
FISA abuse related to the controversial
dossier available to all House members
the report apparently contains
information regarding the dossier that
alleges President Trump and members of
his team colluded with the Russians in
the 2016 presidential election some
members of the House viewed the document
in a secure room on Thursday so what is
likely to be in the document when one of
the big questions about how this entire
collusion investigation got started they
at the FBI is that fusion gps was
compiling an oppo research file paid for
by democrats they funneled that to
Obama's FBI Obama's FBI then took that
and used it as an excuse to go get a
FISA warrant against American citizen
Carter page right so they didn't do it
on their own recognizance the FBI they
didn't do it because they were hearing
from great sources basically they got an
Apple research stump from Hillary
Clinton's team at fusion GPS and then
they used that as an excuse to go after
Trump's team that is the allegation I'll
explain in a second why I think there
are at least two holes in this
allegation that need to be filled in
order for the entire Mueller
investigation to fall apart you can see
the Republicans are really starting to
push this hard so Matt gets is a Florida
congressman and he said yesterday we
need to quote unquote release the memo
they keep saying release the medal this
is a hashtag that was trending releasing
the memo they they they say they want
the memo released to the entire public
and that would really be up to the
leadership of the House Intelligence
Committee I'll explain in a second why I
think that this argument is a little bit
flawed here here's what gets had to say
well Liz the allegations contained in
this important intelligence document go
to the very foundations of our democracy
and they require an immediate release to
the public in my opinion unfortunately I
cannot talk about the specific facts
contained within this memo I can only
share my observation that if the
American people knew what was happening
if they saw the contents of this memo a
lot would become clear about the
information that I've been talking about
on television for the last several
months and so I am calling on our
leadership to immediately hold a vote on
the floor
of the house to make public the key
contents of this intelligence memo
regarding the FBI the Department of
Justice and president Trump ok gets is
not the only person saying this also
mark meadows a member of the house
freedom caucus from North Carolina he's
saying much the same thing that this
memo is shocking and that needs to be
released I'm here to tell all of America
tonight that I am shocked to read
exactly what has taken place I would
think that it would never happen in a
country that loves freedom and democracy
like this country it is time that we
become transparent and all of this and I
am calling on our leadership to make
this available so that all Americans can
judge for themselves ok so there he is
and and this is the this is what
Republicans are trying to trot out the
aside the essence being that this memo
needs to be released now Democrats are
pushing back saying the memo is
basically selectively put together by
Devon Nunez on the House Intelligence
Committee the the Republican congressman
from California they're also suggesting
and I think this is where there are a
couple of obits so here are the couple
of them questions I say the DES
narrative is basically from Republicans
that a FISA warrant was issued against
American citizen Carter beige on the
basis of Apple research for political
reasons I have two questions about this
particular narrative and I think both
need to be answered the first is let's
say that all of this is true let's say
that the FBI began an investigation into
Carter page on the basis of Democratic
Oppo research and let's say the Barack
Obama was behind all of that because he
wanted to finish Donald Trump for the
general election campaign he wanted to
knock Trump out of the race and he
wanted Hillary Clinton to win why didn't
we hear anything about the Russian
dossier until the election right why
didn't we hear that why wasn't it leaked
why was it that the FBI didn't make an
announcement about it right James Comey
came out made an announcement about
Hillary being prosecuted and then not
prosecuted and then prosecute and then
not prosecuted but we never heard a word
one really about Russian collusion
directly from the FBI during that entire
debacle of an election so if this was
all just a setup where Fuzion GPS was
working hand in glove with the FBI and
Loretta Lynch's DOJ and the Obama
administration why is it that we didn't
hear about the Russian dossier really
until January of 2017 so that's question
I have number one question I have number
two is if the ID
here is that the FISA warrant against
Kyra Paige was gathered under false
pretenses that basically the FBI and the
DOJ were working hand and glove with the
Hillary campaign there's one way we can
find this out
the President of the United States has
the has the ability as the head of the
executive branch to declassify any
single document that he wants why won't
he just declassify the FISA application
he could just declassify it you could
just say listen FISA application
demonstrates this whole thing is a bunch
of nonsense I'm declassifying that
application and it shows you that the
FISA application was based on all of
this Democratic nonsense that was taken
up and used by the Obama administration
right why doesn't he just do that so
there are people like Sean Davis over at
the Federalist you know were debating
this on Twitter this morning he would
say well then it would look like Trump
was interfering in the investigation to
which I say everyone on the left already
thinks Trump is interfering in the
investigation I mean this is half of
what this is about them thinking that he
fired call me to interfere with the
investigation or that he pressured rod
Rosenstein in order to interfere with
the investigation so I'm not going to
lay it on Trump's tact I think that's
that's not a good enough excuse I don't
think that it's Trump is tactful and he
really doesn't want to look like he's
interfering and therefore he's not
declassifying the memo maybe that's
what's happening but the very least
wouldn't you have somebody look at the
actual FISA application and leak of that
to the press this administration is
leaked for every other reason so why
wouldn't you leak that so what that says
to me is that it seems like there are
people on both sides who want to hide
some information it seems like they're
Democrats who want to hide the fact that
FISA applications and FISA warrants are
very often gathered with bad info or
that the lengths to which the FBI and
DOJ go to investigate certain matters is
a lot further than they will go to
investigate other matters so it looks
like Democrats don't want this memo to
get out it looks like Republicans don't
really want the FISA application to get
out because the FISA application gets
out it puts an end maybe to all of the
rumors about the FISA application being
based on Hillary Clinton Oppo research
so these are those are my two questions
about this particular narrative
narrative when they're - being that the
dossier the Russians asti a compiled by
Carter page or compiled rather by it by
Christopher Steele the spy under the
auspices of Glenn Simpson and fusions
GPS at the behest of Hillary Clinton
that that was used as the DOJ and FBI is
excuse to go after Trump I think they're
they're a couple of holes in that now is
it quite possible that fusion GPS is
doing something corrupt here is it quite
possible that fusion GPS
was working with the FBI and DOJ sure of
course that's possible and we have
another story today that says that the
fusion GPS group was trying to leak at
Hillary's behest all of the information
in the dossier in the last weeks of the
election in order to finish Trump we'll
talk about that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blinds.com
so blinds.com is the place that you go
to make your house look better because
let's face it when you look at the the
state of your apartment the state of
your home the thing you think about last
is the window coverings because why
bother except that that's really what
makes your house look good very often
I've stayed in a couple of vacation
rentals were they Brandon window
coverings it totally changes the the way
that the place looks and in the feel of
an entire location well that's what
blinds comm is there for right now it's
boring to go to the store and pick out
blinds right and it's kind of expensive
you have to go over to the local retail
outlet and it cost you a fortune but
that's not what happens in blinds.com
they make it really easy for you if
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start with blinds stuck on you
get a free online design consultation
you send them pictures of your house
they send back custom recommendations
from a professional for what will work
with your color scheme furniture in
specific rooms they'll even send you
free samples to make sure that
everything looks as good in person as it
does online every order gets free
shipping and this here is the best part
if you miss measure you do it wrong you
pick the wrong color you screw up
blinds.com will remake your blinds for
free they've made it really easy for you
there's no excuse to leave up the crappy
blinds that make your house look like
the trash heap instead go over to blinds
comm and right now and use promo code
bet and get 20% off everything that's
blinds.com promo club bed you get 20% of
everything that's for wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades and more
blinds.com promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do apply so check that up
blinds.com promo code ban 20% off
everything plus of course when you use
promo code Ben it lets them know that we
sent you okay so is it possible that the
Russians were using fusion GPS as a
cutout to funnel bad information about
Trump to the FBI or the DOJ lease Smith
has a very good piece in tablet comm
basically suggesting this he says
earlier this week Senator Dianne
Feinstein released a partially redacted
transcript of Glenn Simpson's August
22nd 2017 hearing before the Senate
Judiciary Committee
maybe it's a coincidence that just last
week Simpson himself co-founder of the
Washington dc-based strategic
communications from fusion GPS that
assembled and distributed
the now notorious anti-trump dossier
wrote a New York Times op-ed calling for
Republican members of the committee to
release his testimony Feinstein's said
at first she was pressured to release
the document now she says she wasn't and
her statement was misunderstood the
whole fight over the Simpson transcript
is just part of a broader fight about
what exactly was in the dossier was the
dossier used to garner the FISA warrant
against against Carter page in the first
place and here's the problem right
here's the right Lee Smith gets to the
root of he says if the FBI and the DOJ
used a piece of opposition research paid
for by a political campaign as evidence
for a warrant to intercept the
communications of a rival campaign and
the questions asked by congressional
investigators suggests they did we are
now living in a very different America
than the one that generations of civil
libertarians and small government
conservatives alike desire to maintain
and which large majorities in Congress
have repeatedly voted for the DOJ the
FBI perhaps the CIA would be embroiled
in a scandal likely have long-lasting
sweeping consequences for intelligence
collection national security and the
safety and privacy of American citizens
to say nothing of how it will demoralize
federal law enforcement which will
appear to be mired in partisanship and
political corruption so that is the big
question right at that is the big
question is whether the FBI the DOJ the
CIA the Trump the Obama administration
or you know wiretapping Trump supposedly
at the behest of Democrats essentially
so that is a big problem on the other
side there's a big problem which is that
there are a bunch of people who are
still trying to track down a lot of the
allegations that are in the Russian
dossier that are in the Christopher
Steele collusion dossier Glenn Simpson
you know in the Democrats have voted to
release the transcript of Glenn Simpson
the the founder of fusion GPS which was
the Apple research firm the House
Intelligence Committee voted to released
the transcript of Simpson's interview
with them and according to Business
Insider the house investigators line of
questioning touched upon subjects the
Senate Judiciary Committee did not delve
into Democrats basically tried to lay
out a series of breadcrumbs for the
media to follow right what were you
finding Glenn Simpson and then Glenn
Simpson would come out and say well what
we were finding was financial
impropriety and kind of trying to hint
at what it was that was in the dossier
that was substantiated so there's a lot
going on in this whole story and there's
even more going on now that we now we
know according to Powerline blog that
the House Intelligence Committee
transcript shows the Glenn Simpson tried
to leak all of the information
Russians oca2 the press right before the
election cycle which is not surprising
since the DNC was paying for the dossier
in the first place right the fusion GPS
apparently doesn't have much on Trump
but that said they were trying to leak
it before the election so there's a lot
of dirty business going on here none of
it has come out but there are two ways
to solve this right there there two ways
to solve this one the house can release
all the information that it has they can
vote to do that they can release not
only the Glenn Simpson memo the
transcript but also the memo that
they're talking about releasing they
should release it and number two Trump
himself can end this right now all he
has to do is release that FISA
application so I'm calling on President
Trump release the FISA application right
let's find out what it was that caused
the FBI to investigate Carter page
because all of the speculation all the
rumor mongering all the suggestion by
people on the right that you know Trump
is is just exercising propriety
that's not Trump's habit okay Trump is
not a guy who cares much about propriety
and let's be real about this if Trump
were to release that FISA application it
were to say fusion GPS memo is the basis
of the FISA application it basically
ends the Mueller investigation right
then right basically everybody on the
right goes okay well then this was all
set up from the very beginning and that
that's why Trump should do it okay
speaking of things Trump should do Trump
is actually handling this whole
government shutdown relatively well so
the government is going to shut down
today it's going to shut down because
Democrats believe that it is in their
political interest to filibuster the
continuing resolution to fund the
government so there's not a new budget
on the table we're talking about a
continuing resolution that funds the
government for 30 more days as a
sweetener as an attempt to cut Jul
Democrats into voting for the continuing
resolution Republicans are putting in
there a six year funding for chip which
is the Children's Health Insurance
Program as we discussed yesterday they
also are not putting in there anything
about data they want that to be a
separate negotiation they want a
negotiation with Democrats over what
happens to the dreamers they don't want
that included in the continuing
resolution Democrats are saying we will
not vote for anything unless it includes
basically amnesty for 800,000 people who
already have gotten these these passes
basically from the Obama administration
because they were here through no fault
of their own when they were miners and
now they're between the ages of 16 and
30 and have lived in the United States
since the time they were children and
that is is what the Democrats want and
so now they're actually willing to hold
up all funding for the government in
order to get what are essentially green
cards for
immigrants and Trump is right Trump came
out yesterday said listen Democrats want
to shut down right they they want to
shut down because they want to change
the subject from the fact that the tax
cuts are working really well from the
fact that things are going relatively
well on the foreign policy front they
want the government shutdown there's no
question the Democrats do want the
government shutdown by the way because
Republicans if it here's the funny part
if Democrats didn't want the government
shutdown all they have to do is shut up
rooo that's all they have to do the
reason being that Republicans don't even
have a majority in the Senate to vote in
favor of continuing resolution so right
now Republicans have 52 51 votes as soon
as as soon as the Alabama seat flips I
think you're sworn in so I guess they
have 51 votes in the Senate now
Republicans have 51 votes in the Senate
they actually don't have 51 votes for
the continuing resolution so all
Democrats would have to do is say listen
it's on the Republicans whatever they
pass it's on them right then we're not
gonna be complicit in passing anything
Trump does you know this so it's on the
Republicans to pass their own stuff
the problem is Democrats are openly
stating that they want to filibuster the
continuing resolution so if every
Republican voted for the continuing
resolution in the Senate they had 51
votes that's still not enough because
you need 60 votes to break a filibuster
and there is no reconciliation process
when it comes to continuing resolutions
the reason that you could pass the tax
cuts with 51 votes is because there's a
process that we've discussed often on
the show the process is that you go to
the Senate Rules Committee basically
there's a Senate Rules arbiter and you
say to them we want to pass a law that
does not increase the federal deficit
and only changes current federal law and
that we can do a 51 vote and then the
the arbitrator essentially rules the
Senate rules guide rules that that's
okay and you can pass with 51 that's not
the way it works with a continuing
resolution which inevitably increases
the deficit that's what it's there to do
right it is literally there to pay off a
deficit that already exists that's what
continuing resolutions are for is to pay
off obligations that have already been
in cru accrued and incurred so the idea
that Democrats are openly filibustering
a bill that they don't even have to
demonstrate that they actually want the
government shutdown they want to be
blamed for the government shutdown they
think they're winning on the public
relations front when they shut down the
government so we now have this the great
irony we now have the precise reverse of
the situation in 2013 in 2013 Ted Cruz
who did not have a majority in the
Senate led a government shutdown effort
over Obamacare and Republicans caved
they said no we're gonna be blamed for
this that would just be terrible now
demo
that's our leading a shutdown effort and
the same people who are screaming at
Republicans for leading a shutdown
effort in 2013 are saying that a
shutdown effort would be awesome they're
now saying it would be great so here's
Trump saying Democrats want a shutdown I
really believe the Democrats want to
shut down to get off the subject of the
tax cuts because they worked so well
nobody thought including the Democrats
they could work this well they've been
so good that I think the Democrats would
like to see a shutdown in order to get
off that subject that is not a good
subject for them the tax cuts because of
the way they've worked okay and he is
he's exactly correct about this Paul
Ryan he's using this as a club to be
Democrats saying listen they won't even
vote to fund the military they won't
vote to fund children's health insurance
and their garbage I mean this is this is
Paul Ryan's case
Senator Schumer do not shut down the
federal government do not jeopardize
funding for our military and for our
national security do not jeopardize
funding for the children's health
insurance program it is risky it is
reckless and it is wrong this is a
strategy that Senator Schumer himself
has called governmental chaos we
sincerely hope we sincerely hope that
cooler heads will prevail okay so you
know this is exactly it's it's so funny
watching this now happen in Reverse and
it is happening in Reverse this is
exactly what Democrats were saying in
2013 except they were also calling
Republicans terrorists Mitch McConnell
doing the same thing saying Democrats
are shutting down the government over
illegal immigration good luck with that
one the other side are saying here is
they're prepared to shut down the
government over the issue of the illegal
immigration now on that issue there's a
bipartisan interest in solving the daca
problem but the president has given us
until March last time I looked this was
January my colleagues where is the
urgency here okay so I do love the the
role reversal that's happening here at
Mitch McConnell then crawled back into
his shell and sunk back to the bottom of
the pond but it is it is amazing to
watch how the political winds shift this
quickly and in just a second
to show you how quickly they shift I'm
gonna play you some audio of Democrats
demonstrating just how well they have
they reversed themselves on all this
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at policy genius
so every year 30% of people make a
resolution to be more financially
responsible most people do not follow
through well one of the ways that you
can be financially responsible is making
sure that when you die your family is
taken care of so not to get dark or
anything but you're gonna die I'm just
breaking it to you right now you are
going to plot it will happen I know this
with 100% certainty 100 percent of
people who have eaten the healthiest
things died all of them right we will
all die one day now with that bright
cheery message in mind at least make
sure that your family has some money
okay all you have to do to do that is go
over to policy genius it's the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance online
they let you compare quotes in just 5
minute I've tried it myself
it is almost unheard of to make a
responsible purchase about life
insurance in five minutes you can do
that at policy genius they've helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
and they place 20 billion dollars in
coverage it's not just life insurance
they insure everything health insurance
disability insurance pet insurance
renter's insurance there are lots of
ways for you to be responsible with your
cash and that is what you can do over a
policy genius so if you are looking for
a better way to be responsible with your
money and ensure that when you die your
family is taken care of then you need to
go for the policy genius calm no sales
pressure no hassle it is absolutely
financially responsible as I say policy
genius get that new year's resolution
done in five minutes never have to worry
about it again like literally you never
have to worry about your life insurance
again because by the time you're worried
about your dad's it doesn't matter so
check it out over a policy genius.com
and make sure that your family is taken
care of there's no excuse not to do this
go over and do it right now
ok so speaking of absolute
irresponsibility so Chuck Schumer the
Senate Minority Leader who's leading
this filibuster fight let's flashback
all the way back to 2013 I know we have
to go back a really long way so all five
years ago Chuck Schumer like pretty much
this date in 2013 was going around
suggesting that anyone who shut down the
government over an ancillary issue is
doing so for their own political
purposes and then what listen wonder
what about us Democrats what if we
Democrats had shut down the government
over like illegal immigration wouldn't
people go crazy humidor Lee said this in
persuaded my caucus to say I'm going to
shut the government down I'm going
do not pay our bills unless I get my way
it's a politics of idiocy of
confrontation of paralysis it is see
confrontation and paralysis he actually
did spell out another one of these
interviews he actually did spell out he
said listen I could have shut down the
government over immigration reform but
I'd never do that
now it's 2018 fast forward to 2018 and
here we are it's just it is an amazing
amazing thing so who's gonna get blamed
for this right how is the political
fallout gonna play here's the truth I
don't think people care about government
shutdowns I don't think they cared in
2013 I don't think they care in 2018 I
think the press cares I think people in
Washington DC care because their
livelihood goes away letting a bunch of
people in Washington DC who cannot
function if the government doesn't
function like listen I have a happy life
if the government starts functioning the
way that I wanted to and it stops being
a big deal in my life I'll just talk
about other stuff I'll just talk about
the culture which I prefer to talk about
anyway I'll sit here and I'll talk about
Plato and Aristotle and Aquinas I'll do
all those things it'll be great our
listenership may not be as high but
it'll be awesome okay I'm happy to do
all of those things but if you're in
Washington DC if you're the political
press and you spend all day covering the
minutia of all the crap that our
politicians do and then the threat is
the government's gonna shut down we're
all gonna die then this is a big deal to
you is this a deal is a big deal some
guy in Idaho is it a big deal to you
okay here's the reality like 90% of all
government function continues during a
government shutdown you're still gonna
get your Social Security checks nothing
actually stops nothing actually said the
military continues to function right if
a government shutdown continues it never
entirely then at some point the the the
Congress can shift funding around that's
all ready available you know they can
they can make cuts you know I'm all in
favor of government shutdowns I really
have no problem with government
shutdowns the government spends four
trillion dollars a year it seems to me
that a little shutdown wouldn't be the
end of the world
it would be us canceling their credit
card for a month or two I don't think
that's that's the worst thing that could
possibly happen but everybody in the
political press thinks it's the worst
thing that's going to happen they think
for some reason that if we do a
government shutdown and we don't fund
continuing payment of our debt that
people are gonna sell our debt on the
open market it's gonna crush our credit
rating really where those dollars gonna
rush they can go invest in a delay
everything you let go invest in the Euro
okay that's not going to happen because
everybody knows the government shutdown
is going to end so this is why both
parties are sort of sanguine like
they're they're acting as though
the end of the world but both parties
are kind of saying when about the
government shutdown itself so how will
it pay off politically you know the
Democrats will blame the Republicans
that are publicly known playing the
Democrats people in the middle will
probably blame the Democrats because
they'll say the Democrats are shutting
down the government over illegal
immigration then they'll cut some sort
of deal next week and we'll all be done
and that'll be the end of it Republicans
didn't lose seats in 2014 they gained
seats in 2014 after the government
shutdown so this idea that government
shutdowns inevitably hurt the party
perceived to have been responsible for
the shutdown obviously is untrue the
only reason to talk about this is to
demonstrate the apocrypha of the
Democrats cuz in reality so I think this
is going anywhere no I don't I think
that in the end Republic rats will come
around Republicans will toss them some
sort of bone it won't be daca but it'll
be something else or they'll cut a deck
at the old last minute deck a deal and
they'll say okay a little bit more
border security they'll go back to the
original Lindsey Graham plan or
something slightly more lucrative than
that Democrats don't want this thing
continuing out for a full month right in
either a Republican so that means that
this thing will be over inside a week I
think I think the chance of the thing
continues very long or low to my great
chagrin I'd prefer that it continue
forever federal government shutdown
sounds awesome to me like except for
military function I don't I don't think
the government should be doing nearly
anything it's currently doing okay now
on the immigration topic there's
something that's been happening on
immigration it's really nasty and it's
really negative and it's it's it ties
into how conservatives portray their
their position on immigration there are
two really conservative positions on
immigration position number one is the
sort of libertarian position on
immigration this is my position my
position is that people should be
allowed to work wherever they want if
they want to come into the United States
to work and not take welfare I am fine
with that
if people want to come in and become
citizens and we don't actually have a
welfare system I'm fine with that but if
you just want to come here and work and
not vote and not take public benefits I
don't care that's cool it prevents
government it prevents corporations from
outsourcing to foreign shores because
that's the reality when you increase the
price of labour here in the United
States corporations start doing labor
elsewhere they start purchasing their
labor in China or India or Mexico so my
position is very libertarian on the on
immigration but it is not libertarian
when it comes to the idea of people who
become citizens and what their culture
is since we now have a very big
government and we have a government that
has essentially no constitutional
boundaries anymore where the government
can spend what
once can force you to buy whatever it
wants that being the case who we allow
into the country does matter and that's
why we should I think pretty stringently
screen for ideology and philosophy and
skills I think that that would be a
worthwhile thing right that is position
number one that the libertarian but I
would say border security strong
position then there is position number
two the sort of the Jeff Sessions Donald
Trump position and that is that bringing
in foreign labor to is is allowing an
undercutting of the American work force
that we have to protect American
citizens from the predations of people
who want to come here and work for less
money now that you're born in America
therefore you deserve a job and the idea
is that will artificially boost the
price of labor by preventing immigration
into the country so let's make
immigration solely based on skills or if
it is solely based on if it's not solely
based on skills then we should shut down
immigration altogether now both of these
arguments can be made without reference
to race ethnicity both of these
to country of origin right you can make
the strict immigration argument without
reference to country of origin you can
just say whoever's qualified gets in you
can make the libertarian argument
certainly without government of origin
or country of origin you can just say
whoever wants to come in can come in so
long as they're not taking my money
right both of these arguments can fairly
and I think should fairly be made on the
basis of non bigotry non non
discrimination on the basis of place of
origin unfortunately there is a tendency
on the right to shift into some rhetoric
that borders on the bigoted and I think
that obviously the bleep hole comments
that Trump made a week and a half ago
our indicative of the ease with which
some people move into the space toka
Carlson on his show last night
he dropped the question that I thought
was particularly inappropriate and I
don't think actually a good question I
like to tuck her a lot I think Tucker
does a really good show he's super
talented but his perspective on
immigration does a disservice I think to
conservatives on immigration how many
big tech companies are were started by
people from the Central and South
America Latin America so right now I'm
sitting in Phoenix Arizona very close to
a company called Fortis who was though
started by a gentleman from Panama it's
one of our top engineering companies in
this
and they actually are one of our largest
employers of at-risk veterans
she's a wonderful success he's a great
guy in the company's great but how many
big tech companies were started by the
immigrants that you're talking okay so
Tucker didn't like the answer that he
got there the woman actually gave a
pretty good answer no one has that
statistic by the way if I ask Tucker how
many people from Norway have started
companies in the United States Tucker
wouldn't have that answer either if I
asked him how many people from Britain
have started great companies in the
United States you'd say all been a lot
right he wouldn't have that number
nobody has that number right so the
problem with what Tucker is saying there
is number one very often it's the
descendants of people from places of you
know from bleep whole country supposedly
who actually create a lot of these
companies right I created a company my
great-grandparents came here in 1907 my
grandmother had a company but it wasn't
my great-great grandparents who really
started those companies right so the
this idea that that it's only the first
generation that matters is obviously not
true I mean I'm sure that Tucker's the
Tucker I don't know Tucker's heritage
but I assume that at some point somebody
came over here they weren't his line did
not begin in in New York right that
being the case that means that Tucker's
success is due to the United States
being relatively open to immigration
which it was for most of its history and
and I also wanted in in a second I'm
going to discuss here another
perspective is on Tucker's show last
night that also I think does it a
service mark Stein was on Tucker's show
last night and here's what Mark Stein
had to say this this comment is getting
a lot of flack and I think rightly so
here's what Mark Stein had to say about
the state of Arizona and daca and you
and an illegal immigration and
immigration more generally and in fact
to go back to what your Swedish guest
was saying you know whatever the
economic benefits which are minimal and
are not evenly distributed the cultural
transformation which is what's happening
in Sweden other parts of Europe and is
what's happening in Arizona too that's
forever in Arizona a majority of the
grade school children now are Hispanic
that means Arizona's future is as an
Hispanic Society that means in effect
the border has moved north okay I don't
even know what that means the border has
moved north all of those kids in Arizona
who are actually born in the United
State
or the ones who have legally immigrated
those are American citizens why does it
matter what color of their skin or their
place of origin now this sort of
language does no service to those of us
who've been fighting on behalf of a lot
of the same policies that Mark Steyn and
Tucker Carlson want where I think we
probably agree 90% on immigration but
the idea that you can make these
distinctions on the basis of ethnicity
or place of origin as opposed to skill
level you're falling right into a trap
that Democrats want to set and and it
betrays I think the cause of being an
immigration hawks I think that's it
that's a huge mistake okay so I want to
talk about some things I like and some
things I hate we'll get to the mailbag
but for all of that you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire and subscribe so
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire now is the
time to do it by the way right now is
the time when you should do it the
reason being that if you do it right now
you can ask your questions right now you
go over to Daley wire you go over to
watch it live there and then you can in
our chat box ask questions and I will
answer them live for you right now so
now is the time to do it on a normal non
Friday you can also be part of the
Andrew Klavan show or the Michael Noel's
show when you subscribe plus the annual
subscription comes along with this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
the leftist here is hot or cold tumbler
you can get that as well if you want to
listen later go over to iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play stitch or any of
the various podcast apps and you can get
the podcast subscribe to our channel
over at YouTube as well we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty time for a couple of quick
things I like and then a couple of quick
things that I hate really one thing that
I hate okay first thing that I like so
if you missed it earlier this week I did
a Facebook live with my personal trainer
Derek great Derek is a wonderful fellow
and and Derek is 54 years old he looks
like he's about 35 because he's in
tremendous shape his story is really
amazing he is the only male in his
family in three generations to live past
the age of 50 because there's a heart
problem that runs in his family he used
to be in the stock business and he quit
to become a personal trainer because he
wanted to live basically he's written a
book now I wrote the foreword to it
called how to stop being lazy and start
living healthy then it's all about kind
of tips for nutrition and tips for
fitness he also runs a runs a personal
training firm out of Los Angeles and if
you want more information on that I'll
tweet out the link or I'll put it out
over at Facebook as well but it's book
how to stop being lazy and start living
healthy is a fun reading sort of tells
his story and it's a good motivational
read as well so Derek gray how to stop
being lazy and started living healthy
check that out at some point we're gonna
have to start actually posting videos
and me working out Derek I'm always I'm
always concerned about looking south
Cystic about looking narcissistic but
then again everybody knows I'm a
narcissist so should I really care I
mean come on anyway I'll start putting
up those videos as well and you can see
maybe work out with Derek and you can
see me do upside-down push-ups and flip
tires and hit things and and climb walls
using only my arms etc it'll be amazing
okay other things that you know let's go
to a thing I hope will do one thing I
hate and then we'll do the mailbag
so the media are going crazy today over
stories about stormy Daniels stormy
Daniels of course the porn star who had
an affair with President Trump it does
say something about our common culture
that no one seems to care about this I
talked for the last couple days about
why I think that is but one of the
things that there's an idea I want to
talk about briefly that I think is very
silly that is the idea where people say
well maybe we never cared about it maybe
we never cared about it maybe we never
cared that people had affair and we were
just lying to ourselves
maybe politicians were always doing this
stuff like stopping porn stars on the
side and we just were willing to look
the other way but we never really cared
about it you hear the same thing with
regard to every social change right when
when there's a social change in Britain
for example with regard to with regard
to toleration of or the suggestion that
transgender women are actually women and
then the rate of transgenderism goes up
significantly in places like Great
Britain people say well maybe people
were always transgender and they were
just afraid to admit it maybe it's only
the common acceptance that's changed but
people are always living like this they
were just afraid to to express
themselves more fully the human mind is
malleable
okay people behave differently based on
the society that they're in and based on
the social standards that are kept
maybe those social standards are good
when they change right maybe what like
to show how absurd the suggestion is
that people are always the people always
act the same and behave the same and are
not changed by the society around them
look at the toleration for racism in the
1950s versus the toleration for racism
today and you can see that people's
behavior has changed massively how
people think has changed massively the
whole purpose of politics is to create a
communal fabric in which we all live and
that hopefully makes more people happy
right incontinence with freedom
obviously I think this foolish idea that
well that the society has not degraded
at all that maybe we never cared about
politicians having sex with porn stars
know Bill Clinton changed the culture
Donald Trump has changed the culture
again we're moving in the wrong
direction on all of this stuff and I
don't care if you care whether whether
Trump does it but I think for a society
it is not good that we've decided that
character considerations no longer
matter when it comes to the people that
we look up to and that we are now going
to basically define deviants down and
continue to define deviancy down okay
time for the mailbag so let's jump right
in all right Nicholas writes Ben what do
you think the GOP needs to do to avoid
getting clobbered this November well I
mean I think
at the passing some some form of a of a
border security bill would be very
helpful I think that moving toward
moving toward shoring up religious
freedoms would be more than they need to
do stuff right the problem is right now
they they're not doing a lot of stuff so
they did the tax cuts and that is
helpful but they're also going to need
to avoid the taxes India president Trump
Trump is what's driving Democrats to the
polls not Paul Ryan not Mitch McConnell
Donald Trump is driving Democrats to the
polls if he could get his Twitter under
control that would really help Seth does
hey Ben my friend recently told me he
was a feminist so I thought he was crazy
as any normal man servitor might think
he that explained to me the definition
of feminism just means equal rights for
men and women
he said these crazy new feminists have
hijacked the term for their own cause so
but the actual definition of feminism
aren't we all feminists well yes I mean
there's so there's first wave feminism
second wave feminism and third wave
feminism first-wave feminism said women
should be able to work in the workplace
they should be able to vote yes of
course we are all first wave feminists
second wave feminism suggested the
marriage was patriarchal and bad and
that we had a set of social structures
so that women didn't feel like they had
to get married this was stupid third
wave feminism goes even beyond that and
suggests that men and women are
essentially identical in every way and
any discrepancy between men and women
can be explained by societal by societal
failures okay that's that is pure
nonsense so I would say that we are all
at least first wave feminists I don't
know that everybody is a second way of
feminists and then obviously only the
craziest people are third wave feminists
so the okay let's let's look on nick
says dear Ben in your opinion which is
harder becoming a licensed lawyer or a
licensed doctor and why the answer is
obviously a licensed doctor it is
obviously a licensed doctor so being a
licensed because as I have not have I
ever told you that nice doctor have I
ever said that yeah I feel like I've
said that a few times before I am about
my wife the same way that John Kasich is
about his father being a mailman so so
becoming a licensed lawyer requires you
to go to school for three years the last
two years in law school are basically a
waste of time and then you pass the bar
which in most states is not all that
difficult being a licensed doctor
requires you to go to four years of
college four years of medical medical
school and three years of residency at
minimum right and then you have to take
a bunch of board exams and you have to
be relicensed every ten years it's it's
very difficult to become a doctor now
Chelsea
says dear Ben my high school English
three classes reading The Things They
Carried a book written by a veteran of
the Vietnam War so I believe that that
book is not actually written by a vet of
the Vietnam War I think that it's a
fiction book that is written by I've
read the book it's it's written by Tim
O'Brien I don't believe that that Tim
O'Brien was actually a Vietnam vet I
think that that he is just a fiction
writer it is a very good book it's it's
well worth reading in any case it says
it has brought up some good discussion
questions about the justification of war
morals in a time of war and so on I'm
curious what is your take on the Vietnam
War should we have been there was it a
war fought to preserve America's
interests so my take on the Vietnam War
is yes we should have been there yes it
was a design empty to protect America's
interests the loss of the Vietnam War
has been the single worst thing that has
happened to foreign policy in the in
America in in the in America's history I
would say pretty solidly not just
because America quote-unquote lost the
war but because it made it almost
impossible for America to quote unquote
win a war because the idea was that
Vietnam went on so long and drained so
many resources that the idea of taking
over a country until in occupying it
until it had become civilized to Western
ways of life that fell off the table
right the Korean War ended in a
stalemate and at least we preserve the
independence of South Korea and South
Korea is a fully westernized country a
modern Western economy and a terrific
place Vietnam completely following in
America and really being undermined from
within by the American public it
demonstrated that Americans have no
taste for anything resembling a
transformation of a country now maybe we
should never have transformed countries
but then we'd have to explain why we
still have troops in Japan and Germany
the the reality is that once everyone
enters office they all become
quote/unquote neo cons in the sense that
they feel like in order to prevent
violence on America's Shores or prevent
the rise of America's enemies we are
going to have to use America's military
might in ways that people had not
considered right Donald Trump has
basically operated very much like George
W Bush on foreign policy with a few
exceptions even Barack Obama was not a
non interventionist obviously got
involved in Libya which I do think was
not in America's best interest and he's
has been someone who deeply believes in
equality of opportunity but not equality
of outcome how far do you think equality
of opportunity should go well when I say
equality of opportunity I mean the rules
have to be equal for everyone
equality of opportunity is not going to
exist for everyone
just isn't okay it doesn't from birth
some of us are smarter some of us are
dumber some of us are taller some of us
are shorter I do not have an equal
opportunity to play in the NBA but there
are no laws barring me from playing in
the NBA the government's job when it
comes to equal let's put this way I
think the government's job when it comes
to equality of opportunity is to not
pass laws that prevent people from
rising when it comes to the rest of our
duty in society there you know in
informal society our social bonds should
help one another out this is why we have
religious communities where if a child
is not being given opportunity we give
religious scholarships or this happens
all the time if you see somebody who's
poor we give private charity but once
the government starts discriminating
against one group in favor of another
group no matter what the group is then
you end up in a situation where equality
of opportunity is not actually being
provided by the government equality of
opportunity is being stifled by the
government it takes two sides and this
is I think the danger of the tappan in
American society there are people who
believe that the government has to
ensure equality and then there are the
people who believe that the government
does not have to ensure equality and
that social fabric means nothing the
social fabric means a huge amount that
the social fabric is deeply deeply
important and the fact that we have
neglected the social fabric for so long
is I think one of the reasons why we as
a country are coming apart this is what
I'm literally writing a book about right
now I'll give you the tentative title a
little bit later once we've actually
released it but it's it's I think it'll
be a really interesting book with with
some fascinating historical and
philosophical texts
Nicholas's hi Ben is regulation on
business ever necessary a regulation on
business is only necessary to the extent
that regulations on individuals are
necessary regulations on torts
regulations on externalities regulations
on forced labor but in terms of
regulating businesses so that they don't
commit that or that they is that they
are prevented from for example
participating in a business activity to
which there are no externalities no I
don't think that regulation is is
necessary when people say regulation on
business usually they mean we have to
stop a business from acting in a way
that it does not even create
externalities we have to knock down
their profit margin for example or force
them to collectively bargain with their
employees that's that's a bunch of
nonsense Taylor says dear Ben I saw the
California State Attorney General
threaten criminal action against
businesses that assist ice in conducting
enforcement raids is there legal
precedents for the state to criminally
prosecute individuals or businesses
assisting in the enforcement of federal
law no I'm
there's a blatant violation of the
Supremacy Clause if there's a federal
law and you are obeying the federal law
and the state government tells you to
disobey the federal law this is a
violation of the Constitution
this is basic constitutional law the
Constitution of the United States and
federal law take precedence over state
law so long as state law is is not
acting within the purview of the
Constitution or the federal government
is not overreaching Braeden says dear
Ben what exactly does it mean to be
kosher also our leftist to yours kosher
so left this here should be kosher they
are just water with salt in them
presumably I would prefer they be
sterilized obviously what it means to be
kosher is that there's an entire
lifestyle associated with being kosher
being kosher just means what you eat has
to go through certain strictures so
animals have to be slaughtered in a
certain way you can't eat meat and milk
together you have to wait between when
you eat meat when you eat milk some Jews
wait an hour Orthodox Jews wait now are
some Jews wait three some wait six in my
family we wait three you're you have to
go to restaurants that have a Mashiach
meeting a rabbi has come in and taking a
look to make sure that it's obeying all
of the various dietary regulations not
all animals are kosher so they have to
have split hooves and chew their cud so
cows are kosher but pigs are not because
they have split hooves but do not chew
their cud birds have to not be birds of
prey now fish have to have scales and
fins those are those are sort of the
basic rules all vegetables all fruits
are kosher and so our derivatives
they're from so like jams and jellies
are kosher unless they've been made on
non kosher equipment meaning that that
equipment has been used for non kosher
products Craig's has been I got all of
your books as a Christmas gift and been
working my way through them I'm
currently on bullies Ike help I can't
help but wonder what was your favorite
book to write and why my favorite book
to write the most enjoyable book to
write was probably project president
project president was fun to write just
because it's a bunch of historical
research about kind of fun anecdotes
about presidents so that was a kick I
did enjoy writing bullies I think the
least favorite book to write was plural
generation simply because to immerse
yourself in a world of disgusting this
is not a pleasant activity for one soul
mu says on campus today I was handed a
flyer with information about the
on-campus socialist club
I asked jokingly if it was a social
group if they wanted to be the next
Venezuela as I continued to her my next
class the girl cut me off apparently I'm
not as funny as I thought and she took
offense to my joke and needed to let me
know first of all let me stop you there
you probably are super funny socialist
don't have a sense of humor
okay socialism basically outlaws humor
and the USSR was not known for its
inferred sense of humor she told me
Venezuela isn't a socialist country and
the truth
has never been tried aha yes the famous
true socialism has never been tried this
is what we call the no true Scotsman
fallacy and logic right that if your
theory doesn't work you just say why my
net my theory has never really been
tried socialism has been tried in Soviet
Russia it's been tried in China it's
been tried in Venezuela it's been tried
in North Korea it has not really been
tried at least in the in the traditional
government owning the means of
production sense in Europe which is in
many ways more capitalist than the
United States when it comes to its
business regulations anyway she said
moose says moose cow says I scrubbed and
continued my walk I've been think about
it all day does Venezuela have a true
socialist government yes I mean it
abides by all Marx dictates the state
owns the means of production and then
redistributes all the income there from
for us the only thing I disagree with
you on is that suicidal mother should be
allowed abortions couldn't this be
abused as an excuse and even justify
late term abortions thanks Hebrew hammer
so yes but that's why I would be very
careful about who you actually deemed to
be suicidal I think that should be a
relatively strict process by which we
determine whether somebody is actually
suicidal or whether they are faking it
in order to do away with with the baby
Kristen says hi been for a long time I
thought the rectum ah cracy like that of
Switzerland was the best way to
legislate I've heard you criticized the
model I was shocked when I saw the
participation rates and votes have been
around 45% in the last year's do you
think this is a danger to Switzerland
and is it inherent to all direct
democracy what other issues are there
with this kind of system well yes I mean
number one the people who are most vocal
motivated a vote always vote and those
people end up controlling the society
too the number of people who are
actually up on all the issues is really
low and it may work in small countries
right it works in your HOA but it's not
going to work the bigger you get the
bigger you get as a republic the more
direct democracy doesn't seem to work
particularly well simply because people
are not informed on the issue and they
vote based on passion we talked about
direct democracy versus Republic when we
talked about Federalist number nine
no Federalist number ten a couple of
weeks ago here on the program so go back
and listen to that episode I explicitly
contrast direct democracy with the
Republic all right so we have now
reached the end of today's mail Beth be
here next week subscribe so you can be
part of the mailbag get all of your
questions answered we are the Ben
Shapiro show we will be back here next
week have a great weekend
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018